welcome back to the omics logic
bioinformatics for precision medicine
program in this video we will be
reviewing what we have learned in
session two the second session was
designed to take you one step further by
starting your journey towards genomic
data analysis for precision medicine
after completing the session video and
associated resources you will know what
is genomic data what does it contain
how is it organized and what can we find
that is relevant for precision medicine
to briefly review what we have learned
in session two first we laid the
foundational knowledge for genomics and
covered topics such as what is dna code
what do we already know about it and
what kind of answers can we find there
then we learned about the human genome
project which is an ambitious research
effort aimed at determining the dna
sequence and the location of the
estimated 100 000 human genes
further we learned about the difference
between genetic variation versus
mutation a specific type of variation
that can lead to harmful results for
example a change in function that is
harmful is called a notation
next we learn that when analyzing the
genomic data we are looking to find and
characterize the changes in the dna code
and associate them with phenotype we
also discussed about some important
acronyms to remember about genomic
variations such as smv snp and cnb
next we learned about variant calling
and annotation
here we learned that during dna variant
calling the analysis is performed with
fast q files and that there are several
important steps to consider such as
pre-processing mapping variant calling
and annotation
for this purpose we discussed about the
demo pipeline called the breast cancer
mutation oxygen barrier calling for t p
53 gene on t bioinfo server and also
discussed briefly about fastq dam sam
and vca fires
we also learned about how to visualize
the resulting output on jbrowse
we also learned about variant call
format that specifies the format of a
text file used in bioinformatics course
during gene sequence variation
now that we have learned about the
difference between mutations and
variation and how to identify these
variation in the next part now we will
learn about the clinical relevance of
mutations
upon receiving the dna sequencing
results for a sick patient the first
question that is usually asked is what
genes are affected there is not a simple
answer to this question many of the dna
variants are still being discovered
annotated and rigorously analyzed by
diverse team of scientists
for example in cancer the dna variation
can help determine genetic risk
associated with oncogenes but most often
oncologists look for somatic mutations
in tumor suppressor genes oncogenes or
dna repair genes since cancer most often
occurs with age many researchers see the
accumulation of somatic mutations in key
genomic regions such as a combination of
driver and passenger mutations that can
help diagnose cancer early on evaluate
risk of cancer severity and select
appropriate treatment to slow down
inflarable metastatic cancer
next we learned about clinvar which is a
freely accessible public archive of
reports of the relationships among human
variations and phenotypes with
supporting evidence another great
repository to annotate variants for
cancer is cosmic which stands for the
catalogue of somatic mutations in cancer
here one can estimate the clinical
relevance of the variance by comparing
it with list of mutations compiled in
cosmic database
further we also briefly discussed about
loading vsaf file in a data analysis
environment like r for visualization
manipulation and analysis to be
performed on the entire data set at once
to continue learning we invite you to
explore the associated resources for
session two which can prices of course
work case studies and other examples
from literature
the contents of session two correspond
with practical lessons that you can
complete independently available on the
omixlogic portal for session 2 we have
covered concepts based on lesson from
course 3 genomics this course serves as
an introduction to the bioinformatics
subdiscipline of genomics where students
will be familiarized with the biology of
genetics and genetic variation while
considering practical applications
within the full course specific lessons
that are of relevance to session two
include lesson three introduction to
genomics that will give you an overview
of genetics and genetic variation lesson
5 genomic variation in ngs data
practical where you will learn to create
varying colon pipeline to identify
variants between cancerous and
non-cancerous you know
another lesson is lesson 9 advanced
genomics overview that will cover
advanced concepts in genomics including
single nucleotide variants various
terminologies associated with mutations
and file formats that stored variance
data another lesson is lesson 10
analyzing analysis of ngs genomic data
here you will analyze genomic data and
interpret biological insights using
jbrowse the full course contains a lot
more information that you can choose to
explore independently at your own pace
so do not worry about completing all of
them immediately
another great resource that you will
have access to is project 14 breast
cancer oncogene variant calling here you
will find answers to questions such as
what are these harmful mutations what is
their nature to what extent are these
mutations responsible for causing
diseases or disorders how can these
prominent mutations be helpful to
improve prognostication
in the upcoming session three on
phylogenetic analysis and multiple
sequence alignment you will build upon
the genomic data analysis skills that
you learned in session two so if you
have not gone through session two yet
make sure to complete the associated
coursework and example projects listed
before proceeding to the next session in
session three you will learn about data
preparation for performing phylogenetic
analysis and multiple sequence alignment
and biological interpretation of the
outputs you will also learn about
biological implications of identifying
variance of concern topics such as
genome wide association studies and
development of multi-drug resistance in
a pathogen infecting a single host are
also discussed